when I walked in the room how much did
you actually know about me
not much so I was expecting that to be
fair no not much I know the the Bend It
Like Beckham the goal against Greece yep
the fact that you missed a penalty
and the Spice Girl and that's it
to be fair that's quite a lot
I'm Orlando from save our Squad and I'm
KIRO from Sable Squad and we're here to
talk to Stevie pick up some questions
how you doing boys looking very smart
thank you
that looks like you got some questions
for me yeah yep I'm feeling a little bit
nervous
why did you want to become a footballer
I loved playing football from a very
young age it was all I ever wanted to do
obviously I lived in East London but I
supported Manchester United and it was
my dream
what's that look for in your in Your Man
City
suits all right all right well I'm not
sure what's worse Arsenal City come on
I'm going to ask you the same question
why do you want to be a footballer well
I think I loved that sport I think I was
very good at it my life just can't
continue without football I like that's
a good answer Kara for me football
watches again they're like you can fall
in love with it so easily even as an
Arsenal fan
it's like just one of them games where
you don't really have to have to watch
it or know too much about it to really
like get dried again good answer
what's it like to be famous
what's it like to be famous I've been
able to travel to so many places around
the world and different countries I've
been able to play for different teams in
different countries but for me
personally I've met some unbelievable
people I've met Nelson Mandela Michael
Jordan I've met Jack Nicholson you know
all of these great people that you look
up to and you that inspire you I've been
able to meet them so that's one of the
best things about being famous when I
walked in the room how much did you
actually know about me not much so I was
expecting that to be fair no not much I
know the the Bend It Like Beckham the
goal against Greece yep the fact that he
missed the penalty and the Spice Girl
and that's it
to be fair that's quite a lot Miss
penalty I'm not sure what one you're
talking about but there was a couple
Spice Girl obviously yeah gold against
Greece that was a big one and then bend
it like that there you go great movie
Orlando you know too much about my
career before we uh started this I know
the brendale Beckham I know the grease I
know the the penalty Miss and I also
knew that you do the hairstyles like me
yes I know it's hard to believe right I
did that hairstyle right and I did the
braids oh what
come on by the way that was the day when
I had braids I met Nelson Mandela that
was my only regret actually I had braids
when I met actually a great man like
Nelson Mandela you had breeds I had
braids
come on next question next question next
question go move on quick who's your
favorite player when you were our age
and who's your favorite player now my
favorite player when I was your age was
a player called Brian Robson so Brian
Robson he used to play for Manchester
United he used to play for England he
was Captain for Man United and England
he was my favorite player and I wanted
to emulate everything that he did in his
career in mind and luckily I did I wore
number seven for United or number seven
for England and Captain England
nowadays oh my goodness it's hard to
actually pick a favorite player of mine
these days I like mbappe I think he's an
exciting player he's a player that
obviously has already won the World Cup
and done so much in his career but I
think he's got so much left you tell me
who who is your favorite player in the
game now apart from me obviously no no
no apart from me who's your favorite
because you're here because it's a
Manchester United player it's Anthony
nice I love watching him play what do
you like about him the flirt he has and
like as you see his little thing that he
did the other day I bet he'd love that
didn't you even though he kicked out um
yeah apart from me
um who's your present favorite player as
well well from the past it would be
Ronaldinho because yeah his skills like
and his passion is just too good and if
we're talking now it'll probably be
Gabrielle Jesus like I just love his
aggression he's a good goal scorer
actually I think he's the player that's
come in and changed Arsenal as a team
um Messi and Ronaldo well I've played
against Ronaldo once for England we were
playing Portugal in Portugal and I've
met him a bunch of times obviously being
at Real Madrid at Manchester United as
well Messi again I've met quite a few
times played against him for Real Madrid
and he was unbelievable as a player I
think they they are
the best players in the world and they
have been for a long time
or was the proudest moment of your
career luckily I had a long career you
know I had a career that went on for 22
years professionally obviously I started
at Manchester United when I was 14 years
old and I finished playing at Paris when
I was uh 38 years old I think you know
winning the treble for Manchester United
where we won the Premier League the FA
Cup and the Champions League all-in-one
season in 1999 that was a big moment but
my proudest moment has to be being given
the captain's armband for England that
for me you know representing my country
was the most important thing that
happened to me in my career and being
made Captain was the proudest
what was the toughest moment of yours of
your career yeah I think I've had a
couple of tough moments obviously
missing a penalty which everyone seems
to remember
I think I got a bad injury uh when I was
playing for AC Milan I ruptured my
achilles and I got told by the surgeon
that I might not be able to play again
so that was a tough moment but the
toughest moment was when I got a red
card in the World Cup against Argentina
I know you've obviously both remember
that one
um so yeah that probably was the most
difficult moment because
you know people were doubting me as a
player as a professional you know and I
kind of uh went through a difficult time
on and off the pitch but I was at
Manchester United at the time and I had
a great manager Sir Alex Ferguson that
supported me a great uh Team great
teammates and more importantly the fans
at Manchester United got me through the
difficult moments so
you
um what's your favorite thing about East
London pie Mash have you boys had pie
Mash
pie mashing liquor don't tell me
something oh pie mash and liquor I'm 13.
13. yeah liquor not a liquor not as in
alcohol and if a liquor is like a gravy
like a green gravy okay so no I'm gonna
take you boys for pie Mash at some point
in my favorite Prime mash up right and
it's obviously mashed potato it's a
mince pie
and then the liquor is stewed eels and
parsley
can't see that yeah yeah so pie Mash is
my favorite thing about Eastland what's
your favorite thing about East London
the community I think East London has
one of the most diverse communities like
in the world and it has a very good like
economy here as well we're quite stable
in East London so yeah the community and
the economy yeah East London's the best
right yeah of course it is why is it
that Grassroots football is so important
you guys know you know because it's a
community you know I was obviously part
of the echo League when I was when I was
young and I was exactly like you boys
are it's a real Community Grassroots
football it's so important and I think
what we we've done with the show it
really highlights how important it is so
Grassroots is one of the most important
things
in the game in our country especially in
our country
what is the best advice that you've had
in your career my dad always told me to
believe in myself be humble and be hard
working and that was the best advice I
know you're only young you boys what's
the best advice you've been given so far
don't know anything getting your way if
I'm stopping you to get what you want I
like that it was probably about you and
Edwin but you said make an impact
because that didn't only affect me if it
were affecting me in life because I
realized if you make an impact on
someone or something that's how you
really like gain traction and that's
also what like made me get into the
Westwood started 11 as well so I have to
say thank you
I mean it's been a privilege
working on this and being on this
journey with you boys you're amazing
both of you and all the team
I want to thank you very much
good questions and you're looking very
smart thank you
that's what I was the final against the
Barcelona when we
I should have changed at half time and
she's in Parker Messi
that was a mistake
Jason Park against Messi I think would
have beaten what do we do